the passport is the foundation for
modern global travel to get from one
country to another
you need one so not surprisingly
terrorists and criminals and fugitives
have been trying to get their hands on
stolen passports for a long time in 1980
ICAO established the basic standard for
all passports currently in circulation
it had four main features in the upper
right hand corner a unique identifying
number in the middle some basic
biographic data about the person holding
the passport at the bottom the same data
in machine readable form and most
importantly on the left a standard
picture in the old days it was fairly
easy for a criminal to travel on a
stolen Passport
as long as he or she fit the basic
physical description of the person they
stole it from the most important thing
to do was to replace the photograph and
since on old passports the photograph
merely consisted of a physical
photograph covered by lamination all
they had to do was cut the photograph
out replace it and they could travel it
after 9/11 it became clear that the
international community needed a better
passport starting in August 2007 every
new passport issued by the United States
is a modern epass port this new passport
has a number of features which makes
fraud almost impossible first notice the
photograph it's now on the first page of
the document and it's literally embedded
into the page itself so if you cut it
out will be easy to detect by an
official second every page of the
document has sophisticated and distinct
watermarking making it almost impossible
to dr. third embedded in the cover of
the passport is an RFID chip it contains
all the basic information on the
passport itself as well as a digital
picture that matches the picture in the
passports first page ie passports should
be fully phased in among all developed
countries by 2018 by then traveling on a
stolen Passport
will require a lot more than a scalpel a
new photograph and some lamination
[Music]